[Musique]
boulestin il est promené les cartes
devraient être laissés dormir
ok
[Musique]
jo
je suivais d'accord crypto on va faire
une promenade
j'ai un maître et c'est superman un
petit coup de fer à repasser 1peler mois
le géant de fer
mon chien est le meilleur mais il est
pas terrible avec les autres animaux
alors comment ça va chien normal j'ai
mordu le facteur l'autre jour pour qui
ils travaillaient le général zod la
ligue des ombres
la poste évidemment une organisation
secrète restons sur nos gardes
pourquoi il mais si longtemps mon maître
tiens tiens tiens ne serait ce pas la
vie que des justiciers
c'est normal
espace
oh
tu es super fort il devrait beaucoup
plus mort alors qu'il est dans mon
meilleur ami est en danger et vous devez
m'aider on n'est qu'une bande d'animaux
100 mètres fixé mais on est plus fort
que ce que vous croyez
bien vu c'est bon notre flash activé au
monsieur vient d'être écrite
génial je suis le seul qui a reçu aucun
super beau
donc on possède autant de pouvoir
on a le devoir d'utiliser ce pouvoir
[Musique]
désolé tu disais quelque chose
qu'est ce que tu as bien pu boire deux
cuvettes de toilettes et une bouteille
de bobl dit c'est un truc de ouf je
savais même pas que ça existait
maintenant je suis complètement accro
pose toi glh attend et des poils
bouclier canard c'est quoi un bouclier
qu'est ce qui
reste efficace le bouclier ça doit être
extrêmement douloureux
quelqu'un peut changer ses pouvoirs
[Musique]